Hi there!
We need to talk about GAN generated faces
after we spotted this paper beautifully entitled
“Eyes tell all.”
Aaaw.
When did paper titles become this catchy?
I personally do not have any trouble with
making research sexy, as long as there is
no “All you need” in titles anymore.
As you have already guessed, this paper is
highlighting that GAN generated images (at
least with StyleGAN2)
do not render the pupil accurately enough
and therefore, one can build a GAN-generated
face detector upon this feature.
Ms. Coffee Bean saw that this paper received
an enormous amount of attention
on Twitter with reactions ranging from dismissing
the importance of this pupil feature,
because the next GAN generation will fix this
problem anyway, to cases of surprise that
GANs did not capture this human feature!
So, what are the implications of this paper
that highlights the pupil feature in particular?
And more generally, how to tell GAN-generated
images apart from real ones?
This is what we will discuss in this AI Coffee
Break?
Hey, do you have your coffee ready, because
now we begin.
This paper here highlights a problem in GAN-generated
faces:
GAN stands for Generative Adversarial Networks.
If you want a refresher of how GANs work to
produce images, check out our previous high-level
explanation about this.
So the authors investigate how GANs fail to
generate circular or elliptically-shaped pupils
for human eyes.
Therefore, the authors propose a method to
automatically estimate the shape of pupils
and determine if it is human-like enough.
Since GANs tend to generate weird pupil shapes,
this should automatically detect whether the
depicted person is real or generated by a
GAN.
But Ms. Coffee Bean sees here two categories
of problems.
Let’s get to problem number one.
The paper is framed like GANs in general have
this property of generating weirdly shaped
pupils.
But if we look closely into the experimental
section, we see that the authors have quantitatively
estimated this property only with StyleGAN2.
So to generalize to “GAN-generated” in
general is a bit of a sneaky exaggeration.
Do not get us wrong here: It is absolutely
the case that many other GANs have the same
problems with pupils too.
At least when we zoom in a lot.
For Ms. Coffee Bean, the pupil problem is
not that strong.
Which is strange, because the authors
reportedly used exactly the same cool website,
thispersoendoesnotexist.com (do check it out)
to retrieve some StyleGAN2 generations.
In any case…
GAN generation quality is not there yet where
details are rendered well,
just look at the eyebrows and eyelashes too.
These little details are easy to overlook
if these GAN-generated images are used in
settings where pictures are not looked at
in full detail,
for example in bot accounts on social media
where the profile picture is so tiny anyway.
So understandably, there is need for an automatic
bot checker as the authors propose.
But the argument of using this pupil-detector
widely grows weaker because StyleGAN2 won’t
be NVIDIAs last generation of GANs ever
and other parties are training powerful GANs
too.
Especially since GAN-generated face detection
is an arms race, now that the defenders know
of this eye pupil feature, the attackers will
do their best to make the right generations
in the next version,
circumventing automatic GAN generated face
detectors.
So what we can learn from this paper so far,
is that
when zooming in and looking at the tiny details,
we see problems in GAN generations.
It’s not really news that tiny coherent
structure is hard to enforce, look at the
details of hair,
everything about the eyes,
teeth or tongue or lips for example.
Ms. Coffee Bean, should we write a paper now?
Lips tell all?
Just kidding.
But coherent structure over larger distances
is even harder, especially for elements with
highest diversity in the images in the training
set.
We argue that pupils would be the first ones
to be fixed in GAN generation, really, because
that feature occurs in most of the faces.
But structures spanning longer distances in
the image that are only exhibited by a subset
of the data, is far more problematic.
Just look at the background that is highly
diverse in the training data and should be
diverse in the generations too.
It seldomly makes sense, unless it’s uniform.
Like where is this person even situated?
Or look at the ears for example which are
not often featured both in images because
of the lateral angle or hair covering them
up.
This picture was generated by StyleGAN2 too
and look how the ear lobes are at different
heights.
But sure, all these problems are not that
easy for automatic detection with hand-crafted
features like the pupils are.
A funny side-note, the problem with the StyleGAN
generating bad pupils is weird, perhaps unexpected.
But it’s well known that neural nets tend
to pay attention to very weird tiny features,
like tiny details between animal species when
it comes to their fur structure,
while being sloppy on more obvious features
for humans, like learning that dogs usually
have 4 legs.
They surprise us negatively, as much as positively.
Personally, I was astonished when learning
that neural nets even pay attention to visual
chirality, being able to tell whether an image
has been mirrored or not by judging from things
that are statistically more often encountered
in one way than in the other, like buttons
on men’s shirts.
For more, check out our video.
Now, let’s get to the problem number two
of this method.
The authors acknowledge that detecting how
elliptical a pupil is, could discriminate
against people who just happen to have not
circular pupils.
The authors come with no real suggestion here
to circumvent the problem and say that this
is an infrequent phenomenon and “abnormal”
pupils were
not found in the real images of the dataset
they used, consisting of professional photographs!
That this dataset doesn’t contain abnormal
pupils does not mean anything to Ms. Coffee
Bean, since this could be due to a kind of
selection bias.
Therefore, she would like to stress the warning
here, not to use only an eye pupil normality
checker (if at all).
Otherwise, imagine people being told: Sorry,
we don’t allow you to create your Tinder
account because our anti-GAN AI tells us that
you have robot-shaped pupils.
Bye!
So what to conclude?
That humans, given enough image resolution
and knowing where to look for errors, can
STILL know if an image is GAN generated or
not.
But the GAN that is making detection humanly
impossible, is not really that far away from
now, so we need automatic methods that detect
those.
A method based on strangely shaped pupils
is useful for now, for StyleGAN2 and its likes,
but is short-lived – like so many things
in machine learning.
What Ms. Coffee Bean likes about this paper
is that it puts things into perspective for
non-ML experts.
Let us know what you think about the paper
in the comments.
Like and subscribe.
Okay bye!